preso anche la guardarla giallo e in
alto
oggi nuovo episodio monga questa volta
sarà una caccia al tesoro
come funziona questa caccia al tesoro a
lungo prima che scada il tempo dovremo
uscire fuori in giardino e recuperare
tutte le armi di among us per chi
recupera per primo tutte le armi può
tornare quale dovrà cambiare colore alla
lampada scrive con il proprio colore e
riesce a fare tutto questo prima che
scada il tempo avrei vinto il turno è
potrei aprire una delle mystery bag che
contengono una sorpresa un regalo un
misterioso eroe è un altro creates a una
delle armi o più delle armi è colpi
l'altro kuwait l'altro più mente deve
rimanere immobile per dieci secoli sia
ancora più difficile sarà super
divertente e infatti questa caccia al
tesoro non è un gioco di squadra è una
spina l'ultima
in più durante il video anche voi avrete
delle tasche perché anche voi siete i
nostri crew mezzo ma che sia tutto un po
strano
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn se
questo video raggiunge i 20 mila mi
piace ci sarà un'altra caccia al tesoro
iniziamo con il primo
praga è ovviamente giocato noi anche la
nostra bassotti berlino il cagnolino lui
sarà il nostro in tante pronti tra 3 2 1
dobbiamo subito trovare qualche arma
così se abbiamo almeno un'arma potremo
colpire vita né e fermarlo per diversi
secondi che sta facendo
va beh non ho tempo c'è qualcosa qua ho
trovato circa mentre la famiglia lascia
di new jobs lascia lascia lascia la
chance
giugno cattivo
successo sofferto il martello rilanciato
il martello tu hai un arma in mezzo due
e mezzo ha bloccato e ora prende questo
che prenda con l'astuzia già il 3 2 ora
rimanere fermo presenti come lei ho
recuperato tutte le armi e quelle che
non ne avevano rubato a vitale ora mi
manca solo una cosa da fare
devo cambiare il primate con il mio
colore eccolo qua
mettiamo il rosso 8 9 e 10 ha vinto il
round
nola già cambiato il rosso ha
conquistato la cosa nel primo nodo
vittora possa scegliere la misti bang ma
prima una task per voi lasciate un mi
piace troppo a tre secondi notte cercano
dose liam ora la mistery pec belga testa
già alla media un po cosa c'è
diamo harry potter perché più riposo per
ruby c'è scritto che è una bacchetta
misteriosa potrebbe capitare una
bacchetta di questi personaggi
abbiamo godervi capito da una bacchetta
che mi è capitata è quella di victor
krumm
questa è la bacchetta e questo è il
piedistallo
pensavo fosse un po più grande questa
bacchetta e fra pacchetto e miliardi era
ovviamente alla fine vincerà la
challenge chi riuscirà a conquistare più
per i back to say c'è il vantaggio nel
già presa murano giusto siamo 1 a 0 e
alla fine del video voglio per
descrivere quale è stato mentre mi
ribello preferita ma ora passiamo due
c'è proprio qualcosa qui attenzione è il
martello malefico andiamo andiamo
orbitale ha già trovato un'arma
sa di vino misto ha mostrato erba
ripresa meno acuto ultima arma dove sarà
presa anche la colpa o tutte e quattro
le armi qui così va a correre così ogni
gioco
se lo facciamo tutto dal touch a tutte
le armi qui lo posso dimostrare uno
arrivato di nuovo aiuto ci posso credere
non è stato difficilissimo e difficili
si può portare in giro quattro armi
celeste lavoro e adesso posso scegliere
la mia vista di back beat ripensi allora
secondo me c'è qualcosa di bello in casa
coi rosa quindi scelgo questa qui costa
6 aprile vediamo tutte cose colorate fa
destro chiusa
benissimo adesso prende il volo
vediamo vediamo se decolla non è un
nuovo colore del great evitare al suo
nuovo cappello che ad ora si è
innamorato è stato con questo cappello e
tutto colorato possono scegliere uno di
questi colori per la lampada segnato 6
giallo colore del cappello non cambia il
colore del crew mento ma questo cappello
che ti piace più del cappello del vaso
con fiori deciso ci devo pensare a chi
questo è molto bello
bene è pronti per il terzo round e sarà
dura come va veloce con quelle licapa
posti amato il martin posso fermare
vietata
fate niente meglio che mi allontana
si darebbe
non ti ami girare qua non c'è niente sta
cercando di colpirmi per rubarmi l'arma
giallo più colpita arrivano immobile e
ora che rosa immobile posso continuare a
cercare le armi non riesco a trovarle
però nel sottotitolo zaia non mi hai
neanche rubato l'arma quando vi è
immobilizzato peggio per te
passati dieci secondi
non è brutto il pirata immobilizzato
eccola qua e vitale ancora immobilizzato
guardate l'elica con il vento troppo
pulita la prenderà il volo
o no ho bisogno di più spinta e lega
forza mai scappato
[Musica]
un colore giusto
ecco tutte le armi questa volta delicati
ha dato un po di spinta ma la gente è
stato un mix tra box
se avete visto lo scorso episodio amo
guston nascondino sapete che altri
mister i mega abbiamo aperto anzi la
vostra seconda tasker rispondere a
questa domanda qui che è personaggio mi
è capitato nello scorso video di harry
potter
scrivetelo nei commenti vediamo chi
risponde correttamente chi si sarà in
questo
[Musica]
che carini gli occhiali occhiali quarto
e ultimo round fronti 32
presto pronto presto controlliamo bene
sugli altri non c'è niente che ancora
giallo e legge le stai andando trovato
un'arma e in alto
si è auto colpito ora deve rimanere
fermo per dieci l'elica non ti è servita
in questo caso poteva semplicemente
azionarlo e volare sopra il ramo grazie
a tempo scaduto l'hack è vuota è caduta
in testa inviate non si vede ma guardate
che cosa ho trovato qui presa sono
riuscito a farlo cadere
anch'io ho una falsa purtoppo sarà una
battaglia alla prima arma non ci provate
ci provare
no no no no aiuto aiuto mi dispiace per
te evitare penso che vincerò io questo
round a tutte le armi si bene va da
cambiare le lampadine avrò vinto
l'ultimo 6 berti ha ammonito ho trovato
tutte le armi fu adesso perche e non ha
trovato tutte le armi se ce n'è una a
libero vero berlino ad essere così
allora un piano b ma prendiamo l'arma e
come ultima arma facciamo un predone
subito grazie e avere dimenticato che
erano quattro e arbitri io tu hai fatto
le armi adesso no
pulsante giallo giallo dove ho vinto io
l'avevo dimenticata
era proprio vicino la porta eroe
dimenticato hanno preso il mio ultimo
box il mio bello è l'ultima che cosa c'è
dentro un gomitolo di lana no dei figli
che cosa solo questo è un giochino per
merlino una parrucca forse una treccia
[Musica]
capito perfino limiti sia berlina vi
darete trasformato in un tweet in casa
bellissima questa barbara così provetti
berlino è scioccato non lo riconosce
vita che voto date abita nevicando da 1
a 10 dove sta benissimo ed è freddo
ciò che fa a berlino no ma in poi
chiamatemi harris ha detto prima io mi
riconosci che sono i colossi che sono
sempre io berlino ultima tusk per voi da
parte di eni true story commenti quale è
stata la vostra mystery bag preferita
una mia ashton indecisa tra il
personaggio di harry potter anche il
cappello è lì che era bellissimo questo
perché adoro questa parma per me invece
cappellan elica arrivare il mio
preferito scioccato dai suoi quattro
figli che fanno questo è completato
tutte le tasche
avete vinto anche voi la challenge noi
siamo rimasti pari perché due turni le
ho mentito rotture pienamente vitale
quindi se volete laribi ci vogliono
rivincita con altri cappelli matti caso
non beve veste questo video raggiunge i
20 mila mi piace ci sarà una seconda
parte della caccia al tesoro alla mente
scriveteci nei commenti se volete
cambiare le regole se volete delle
regole diverse scrivete nei commenti e
ha ora vi lasciamo un pò 4 castellina di
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
ammiccante su quella che preferite buona
misura i rapporti di anita story e
vitali
il primo giro già